I want to command you you get you get
these really good acting parts for such
a you know you've such a successful
stand-up career but you're getting these
great parts I'm very low constable Bob
on justified yes Timothy Olyphant on the
other night he's one of my favorite
people I love that show and that was a
great part for you yeah I get a lot of
um I'm very lucky that I get a lot of
good movie and and TV parts and and I
think for me because you said as it as a
stand-up I just love that
I get to bring so much laughter and joy
to people through the parts that I get
you know that's I think the main thing
if you watch everything I've ever done
on TV it's just about like bringing hope
and positive vibes to pizza that's what
I really love the most
really oh yeah I mean that's funny you
say that because we have a clip here we
put together a montage of many of your
television appearances oh wow so this so
these are all the moments that I think
I've brought some joy and maybe a little
glimmer of light to people's live okay
[Music]
like dead yeah weird it does it does
feel like I'm just wondering if I have I
pissed some every rule you a clear app
kick that if someone looks at a script
it was like okay torture and paint
Oswalt get it